bonsoir bonsoir c'est quoi cette chambre
[Musique]
messieurs dames bienvenue dans la vidéo
spéciale Halloween il y a quelques jours
on a eu un trait d'horreur spécial ça
qui soit à l'occasion du lancement des
précommandes de la bdblick aujourd'hui
c'est la vidéo Halloween et cette année
on a voulu faire un truc spécial nous
sommes avec Mehdi coucou du bruit
[Musique]
sur ce qui nous attend on est en bas de
c'est rien en fait on sait rien pour de
vrai bon vous allez tout comprendre je
vous explique ce qui va se passer
aujourd'hui tout nouveau concept et dis
as-tu déjà joué à des jeux d'horreur
jamais aucun jeu d'horreur
c'est littéralement un jeu d'horreur
mais dans la vraie vie incroyable je
sais juste qu'il va y avoir des énigmes
des personnages qui vont nous faire
Bader probablement des objectifs à
accomplir le tout pour aller au bout du
jeu j'appelle ça le jeu car tout comme
toi je ne sais pas ce qui nous attend
aujourd'hui il y aura pas de cadreur
c'est nous la forêt on est tout seul
quoi c'est la première fois que je fais
un tournage je vais être tout seul avec
toi avec mon meilleur pote ça fait quoi
combien de temps qu'on se connaît
maintenant trois jours vous allez donc
suivre l'aventure on va vivre via les
GoPro qu'on a sur nous je pense qu'il y
aura des caméras autour de nous qu'on
verra pas forcément d'ailleurs ah oui
aussi en équipement on a notre téléphone
on a que ça ce téléphone va nous servir
pour nous éclairer avec le flash prendre
des notes et prendre des photos et des
vidéos et le but c'est au bout de ce jeu
médié je suis chaud tu as déjà fait des
escape ouais tu as gagné les escape game
j'ai fait des escapes
moi les gars je vous dis je suis excité
comme une puce mais vraiment franchement
pour Halloween c'est ça me fait trop
plaisir j'embrasse maman et je l'envoie
le bisou en l'air quand je fais ça vous
savez que c'est attention les gens c'est
nope 6 de ce jeu le grand JD le fameux
la légende a besoin d'aide nous nous
rendons sur les lieux pour voler à son
secours
on y va
[Rires]
donc là tu as mis tes pieds là le jeu il
commence enfin y est c'est parti
je mets mon flash on voit vraiment rien
je deviens parano parce que comme on est
en mode escape game j'ai trouvé un deux
points 5 c'est dans le jeu tu penses
pour le prend le je prends comme ça s'il
y a une grosse araignée grosse pour la
claquer je vois une lumière là-bas on
est d'accord que c'est déjà très
stressant
vous savez pourquoi vous êtes là est-ce
que vous avez déjà entendu parler de
l'histoire de la famille bridar non en
fait c'est une maison qui fait beaucoup
parler d'elle en ce moment sur internet
il y a pas mal d'abonnés qui m'ont dit
vas-y va faire un truc là-bas tu vois et
c'est une maison qui est lié à des trucs
étranges des trucs bizarres des trucs je
regarde partout parce qu'il y a des
trucs très étranges qui se passent dans
cette maison on parle de disparition de
personnes des choses comme ça tu vois on
sait pas exactement c'est pour ça que
Lucas Mehdi vous allez rentrer dans
cette maison et le but c'est d'enquêter
de savoir ce qui se passe et pour ça
vous avez justement des téléphones vous
allez prendre des photos essayer de
prendre un maximum d'infos tu m'écoutes
il est très réconcée je suis en train de
serrer ça tellement
je pense il y a l'empreinte de ma main
dans le manche maintenant donc voilà ça
c'est l'info de base ok moi je serai
avec vous tout au long de cette enquête
donc si vous avez besoin d'un conseil
directement si vous êtes perdu etc vous
pouvez me poser des questions me parler
ok parce que j'ai réussi à placer deux
trois caméras dans la maison et je me
suis fait un petit QG ok ce soir vous
avez rendez-vous avec Sylvain bridard
c'est le fils de la famille qui habite
juste là-bas
je vous ai réservé deux chambres et vous
allez passer la nuit à l'intérieur ok on
est au milieu de nulle part donc c'est
très important de quitter ce lieu avec
un véhicule
j'ai trop peur ok à partir de maintenant
je vais aller mettre en place dès que je
vous dis Go dans l'oreillette vous allez
frapper à la porte et c'est selon vous
je n'ai jamais vu comme ça
Lucas
il fait plus peur que la maison sur
terre est-ce que vous êtes prêts ouais
je crois qu'on est prêt hein à la porte
de la maison et dire bonjour à Sylvain
merci mec c'est parti mes caméras sont
en place à eux de jouer
en plus
[Musique]
bonsoir on a déjà vous êtes Sylvain
ouais
bienvenue merci beaucoup à la maison
alors que je vous explique un petit peu
voilà c'est une maison qui a construit
mon grand-père en 1925 donc voilà c'est
une maison habitée à l'année donc il y a
tout un confort voilà vous avez
évidemment wifi le code est près de la
box c'est un petit peu vous voyez un peu
cabane au fond des bois quoi ma mère est
un peu passionnée de taxidermie donc
voilà de trois animaux paillettes voilà
et puis sinon bah écoutez cuisine toute
équipée il y a tout la vaisselle frigo
bon il doit pas rester grand chose les
derniers locataires ont dû laisser deux
trois bricoles mais bon on pourrait
faire un marché demain à Sarclay sans
problème
alors juste pour vous dire moi je vis
dans la dépendance qui est juste en
dessous voilà qui est allumé ok s'il y a
le moindre souci vous n'hésitez pas
que vous dire d'autre c'est une maison
ancienne donc de temps en temps il y a
des petites pannes d'électricité ça pas
souvent mais c'est arrivé une ou deux
fois donc dans ces cas-là pas
d'inquiétude les plombs sont à la cave
je suis seul à avoir les clés donc vous
n'hésitez pas vous venez me voir de la
même manière voilà on va monter alors
oui si alors j'ai un petit souci je suis
désolé on a eu un petit problème de
toiture ouais et donc on a eu un petit
dégât des eaux dans une des chambres ok
ok donc la chambre de gauche est
condamnée pour l'instant j'en suis
désolé donc il nous reste plus qu'une
chambre on va essayer de faire au mieux
une seule chambre il y a un grand lit
dans la chambre
c'est quoi la vitesse
bon allez on va monter je vous en prie
après après vous on va c'est la cave
c'est ça on c'est la carte mais bon on
stocke des trucs ok ah attendez
excusez-moi bon j'ai une petite urgence
parce que je vais faire c'est que je
vais vous laisser explorer là-haut vous
n'hésitez pas seulement de soucis je
vous laisse vous installer ah oui et mes
clés sont là hein les clés sont là donc
on a pas les clés de la cave ça c'est
vous ah non non ça c'est les clés bah
pour rentrer sortir très bien ok merci
bonne soirée au revoir
[Musique]
[Rires]
écoutez à partir de maintenant regarder
autour de vous si trouvé un maximum
d'indices faites attention quand même
mais c'est parti mec moi j'étais bloqué
sur les années moi en paille je fais
employé pardon on est dans la chambre si
jamais
pour moi
amis fidèle et prudent vaut le meilleur
des parents vous savez qu'on est là pour
comprendre quand il est disparition et
tout il y a forcément un truc avec ça là
un lecteur CD mecs
c'est quoi Coldplay non ça sert
littéralement
les mecs vérifier déjà que Sylvain est
bien parti retourner au salon
[Musique]
de la maison on a tout on est enfermé il
nous a enfermé derrière lui mais c'est
trop chaud de faire sa mecs
on est enfermé dans la maison
ça commence mal il va falloir trouver
les vraies clés pour ouvrir les portes
OK
où est-ce qu'on met des clés
comme ça mais c'est les pires cela c'est
vrai juste tout de suite toi c'est quoi
cette photo là bah il y a une fille de
fille mais attends je l'ai vu là ça
regarde je l'ai vu là il y a un mec en
plus ouais qui est là aussi mecs c'est
pas ça [ __ ] de baraque mec moi j'ai
une petite sœur de poule je te le dis
comme je pense là c'est une petite
surprise c'est la maison
gros ça fait flipper de fou
attendez attendez qui c'est qui a joué
du piano il y a un truc sur le piano
j'ai mal attention
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand vous le
touchez et ça demande un code et c'est 4
chiffres il faut quatre chiffres là il y
a un carnet de notes il y a peut-être
des notes dans ce truc
c'est quoi ça c'est du ok je sais pas ok
JD on est en train de fouiller un petit
courant si on trouve un truc Mehdi
on continue continue
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette enveloppe
ok ok
c'est un truc qu'on peut déchiffrer de
nous mais genre sur une table
logique à capter en fait je pense aussi
ça faisait
ABC est-ce que jour tu remplaces je suis
pas des consonnes ou des voyelles les CD
c'est forcément le la exactement ok j'ai
cédé c'est le CDR c'est les donc le r
C'est un S donc c'est une
lettre plus tard si c'est de plus tard
moi je pensais que c'était genre ça d e
une lettre après
continuer
dans un des quatre photos de mes parents
se trouvent de quoi comprendre mon
portable tout dans sa main ok ça se
passe tout dans le salon et il faut
absolument déverrouiller ce portable
attends mais de mes parents
il y a des photos d'ancêtres là-bas
chaque indice qu'on trouve nous amène
vers l'indice d'après l'enveloppe nous
amène vers les cadres les cadres vont
nous amener vers le prochain truc photo
et mon gosse énormément
non ça c'est mort
où ça finit par 3 ou c'est une échelle
en haut à droite ok très bien très bien
vous avez bien checké du début on a oui
[Musique]
ça c'est le [ __ ] de clavier du
téléphone c'est bon reprenez le portable
et faites un bilan de ce que vous avez
vu le portable
le premier chiffre c'est soit à 4 fois 6
voilà et le deuxième c'est soit 1 soit 9
exactement 6 7 2 1
c'est pas ça vraiment vraiment faites
gaffe de pas bloquer le portable en mode
je pense que vous avez pas mis l'effet
ensuite ça peut être 4 c'est 7 1 2
on va le bloquer je te jure
30 secondes et on a plus droit à
l'erreur on a plus droit à l'erreur ok
j'ai des on a essayé le dernier le
premier et c'est le deuxième ou
troisième logo Sylvain n'est pas là
si cette neuf deux j'espère que c'est ça
il y a une vidéo
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est une vidéo
où il y a il pioche dans un une sorte de
fleurs où il y a plein de fruits rouges
il cache un truc genre comme si
camoufler un truc là comme si cache un
truc donc ça c'est dans la chambre c'est
aussi
[Musique]
moi je suis toujours pour laisser aucune
trace
c'est la clé de cave c'est pas pour
sortir parce que c'est pas une serrure
comme ça mec Noémie c'est la chambre de
la petite 100%
ok il y a plein de trucs il y a des
radios il y a des chiffres sur des
post-it je le trouve toujours nos
arrières métiers il faut fermer la porte
ok regarde c'est on dirait des victimes
seuls les cinq articles portant le nom
de Charles Vaudère m'intéresse OK et il
y a des numéros avec cinq photos à mon
avis ces photos sont importantes
par là dans ce bordel les articles on
cherche on tient au courant on cherche
on cherche
ah ouais le corps d'une petite fille a
été substitué à celui de oh là là
vous avez le temps
ok vas-y il faut qu'on rassemble tous ce
journal
tout ce qui ressemble à ça
non c'est pas le même sur le bureau il y
a des trucs
[Musique]
ça m'a fait trop bizarre de tomber sur
le journal qu'il y a danse quoi
[Musique]
je suis arrivé je regarde ça il y en a
devant vous sur le mur
oh [ __ ] mais on est con merci JD
merci frérot tout le temps qu'il y a
nous quel flash comme ça
OK et au dos il y a quoi le numéro des
trucs
il y a un code là qui est doré un truc
qui est pas moi je vous la pièce
JD tu peux mener un code pourquoi en
fait là
dedans le mec attends je vais trouver
attention
[Musique]
le plus important c'est celui qui a
affiché devant vous ok donc il faut
mettre en rapport ça et ça exactement
les enfants et les articles en fait
raison une jeune femme à cheveux longs
taches de rousseur c'est la 5 c'est la 5
que des Girard fait la 4 un enfant a
disparu sur les 7 races donc ça c'est la
1 c'est bien ça le bonhomme est acheté
un son épée il y a un mec qui a un
bonnet
c'est tout con c'est soit ça soit ça
[Musique]
cher journal je vais te dire tous mes
secrets et surtout mes pensées les plus
profondes ça se trouve c'était un proche
de la famille sylvain-là qu'on voit ok
mes parents que j'adore ok on avait
compris ça mais
dites-moi c'est ta caméra qui fait un
œil rouge
j'ai envie de m'asseoir 10 minutes
continuez vous êtes bien dessiner tous
les jours pour devenir illustratrice
et elle est morte
ce que tu fais Jordan m'a dit qu'il a
entendu des rumeurs chelou sur ma maison
askip les anciens locataires auraient
disparu du jour au lendemain ah bon le
proprio est trop chelou je le vois
traîner autour de la maison c'est
vraiment creepy d'avoir un gars qui vit
dans notre jardin c'est Sylvain c'est
Sylvain il parle de la maison la
dépendance là-bas
les parents passent de plus en plus de
temps avec l'autre bridar je sais pas
pourquoi mais ses potes et lui ils ont
l'air chelou ils me mettent grave mal à
l'aise hyper intéressant il y a deux
pages qui manquent ok mais c'est le
texte a été écrit sylvain a toujours un
tel qui va le cul dans sa dépendance je
sais pas avec qui il communique
là-dessus trop bizarre j'essaierai de le
récupérer à l'occasion pour en savoir
avec un mec qui est dans la cave ils
discutait avec un mec et dans la cave
tout est déchiré oh mon dieu quelqu'un
vient de fermer ma chambre à clé et a
pris mon téléphone continue c'est très
bien c'est un cauchemar je les entends
ils ont emmener mes parents dans la cave
j'ai peur je ne veux pas mourir waouh
alors on est sur un j'entends plus mes
parents il faut que j'aille les aider il
est clefs de la cave ne peuvent être que
dans la dépendance de oh non on va
parler dans la dépendance
c'était quoi ça aucune idée mais tu vois
rien non c'est un peu coupé
bon ben on va dormir là tous les deux
c'est good c'est good pour pour la
taille c'est pas grave ouais je vais
dormir
tout me fait peur ça y est ça y est
allez-y
mais là il y avait quelqu'un il y a 2
secondes
je pense
et de choper les clés
je suis vraiment désolé
discrètement dans la dépendance discrète
qui se casse en voiture
les gars c'est la première fois qu'on a
accès à cette pièce c'est vraiment une
aubaine il va falloir fouiller et
trouver des informations donc là on
cherche les clés de la cave ok
c'est humide
mec c'est pas des blagues en fait j'ai
vu des chats tout à l'heure j'ai une
phobie des chats ah mec il y a du sang
sur la pelle on fait pas du ça
c'est Toki avec lequel il parle à son
pote qui a la cam c'est
pas de contacter son pote non on va se
faire griller
des clés non on va se taper une énigme
son dressing
j'ai pas envie de mettre mes mains avec
ça je te le dis ah ouais ouais je m'en
bats un truc mec non ça là forcément un
truc
l'écrivez-moi le contenu oui c'est lui
frère c'est lui c'est lui gros
[Musique]
frère qu'est-ce qui se passe
et nous avertis
les mecs vous pouvez me décrire c'est
des photos de nous en fait
une photo d'avant que j'avais une
Camille ce que j'ai moins cher voilà
c'est pas possible
je vais dans la maison je vais essayer
de les choper il arrive attends il a dit
quoi et bien en place il a dit sous le
totem non j'ai rêvé j'ai trop regardé
Koh-Lanta
totem autour de vous non mais ça doit
c'est peut-être dans la maison le totem
attendez quoi il y a du mouvement
[Musique]
je crois que Sylvain est revenu
il va falloir sortir tout doucement on
va se cacher dans le jardin sortez et
aller dans le jardin mais on n'a pas les
clés c'est pas grave
il faut sortir
[Musique]
fils de [ __ ]
on cherche les clés sous un totem il y a
pas de tote
depuis la maison
à toi
c'est sous le totem attends il y a une
pelle il faut peut-être creuser
merde
[Musique]
dans la dépendance il faut
vous avez la clé avec vous OK
c'est très très bien
oh frère
[Musique]
je vois pas très bien la pièce
regarde une sorte de mausolée mec
il y a des [ __ ]
le rituel des radis va être écrit en
l'an 1800 par la première ligne des
bridares une famille qui entretient des
rides anciens de sacrifices c'est des
sorciers insectes
avant la nouvelle lune pour ça ils ont
besoin de deux personnes à sacrifier et
du totem et là c'est plus clair
[Rires]
[Musique]
je pensais pas ça les gars il va falloir
accélérer il y a du mouvement dehors
vite on a pas longtemps tout est bas
dans
[Musique]
exactement ce que je n'ai pas eu le
temps de faire photographier les
dossiers des membres dans l'ordinateur
dans l'enveloppe le mémo de Charles
woder je ne peux pas le traduire
incertain des lignes des mots et c'est
donne une lettre à chaque fois et un
lieu un certain c'est le nom du livre je
suppose mais bon vous avez un livre qui
s'appelle comme ça
[Musique]
page 94 ligne 13 Mo 4 lettres 7
c'était pas en majeur le truc qui était
dommage
là il y a un truc membre imminent
les autres c'est que des membres du Haut
Conseil en fait il y a Arnaud Laurent
Poirier Gabriela Vaudère Charles
pontaville Maximilien et il y a Thomas
René ok on a ça
la cuisine
entendu où étaient les clés de la
voiture assis dans une
cabane je vais vous donner un timing il
va falloir retourner dans la dépendance
OK
[Musique]
ferme la porte ferme ta porte
il faut vraiment qu'on se casse parce
que là ils ont commencé le truc vite à
la clé dans ta main j'ai la clé c'est
une Fiat vous avez des téléphones avec
vous vous avez des preuves on a tout on
a tout frère
la voiture elle est posée sur le côté tu
passes par la maison à gauche tu passes
la terrasse et il y a un petit chemin
vers la gauche je prends quand même la
photo de Mehdi moi je vais prendre ce
chapeau non c'est dégueulasse c'est bon
vous allez pouvoir sortir tout doucement
allez-y
ou quoi
[Applaudissements]
la voiture la voiture
partie
dégager de cette maison
tu as déjà conduit
[Applaudissements]
bougez pas je vous rejoins
dans la voiture je m'en bats les
couilles
fous mec comment un moment ça s'accélère
ouais mec moi il y a un moment les gars
où je j'étais plus là j'étais à autre
genre merde on va mourir bonsoir je
pense
je perdais mes moyens dans le stress et
je les voyais arriver et je fais mais
pourquoi pourquoi je démarre pas il a
posé une question
une conduite différente on a vécu trop
de scènes de films les chats notamment
les chats mecs moi j'ai buggé je me suis
dit pourquoi il y a autant de chats les
gars est-ce que vous avez kiffé
incroyable je pensais que ce serait
limite un peu plus évident genre en mode
on va voir peur des mecs vont venir nous
faire peur un peu plus exactement là
c'était beaucoup plus réflexion entre
guillemets et genre vachement immersive
tu sais pas moi le Sylvain il m'a mis
dans un mood mec tu sais il était
tellement naturel bon là il y a
l'équipement
de lui je vous le dis mais j'étais
tellement dans l'ambiance genre vraiment
ça s'accélère en fait quand on rentre la
chambre de Noémie
c'est le bordel moi c'est là où
franchement mais perdu les gars devenez
fou je voulais prendre des couteaux et
tout pour qu'on se défendre
des escaliers il y avait vraiment un mec
dans les escaliers
est-ce qu'on peut applaudir s'il vous
plaît
monstrueuse vidéo d'Halloween bravo tout
le monde on le voit pas forcément dans
les vidéos mais ça impliqué énormément
de gens et franchement mais à vivre
incroyable mec c'était dingue il y avait
des petites références à Blic et j'ai
particulièrement aimé ça en a lancé les
précommandes d'une BD horreur il y a
genre 9 jours qui s'appelle Blic et donc
il y a eu des références qu'elle est
là-dedans vous l'avez commandez vous là
vraiment incroyable ouais je crois vous
êtes vivant ah oui c'est vrai c'est le
plus beau Halloween de ma vie aussi mais
c'était le seul à mon frérot
ça va aller ça va aller mon frère bon
les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo
j'espère que ça vous a plu merci encore
à vous deux pour votre participation le
grand JD Mehdi Mazy n'hésitez pas à
passer voir leur travail ces deux
personnes qui font du contenu que
j'affectionne légèrement donc foncé
franchement c'est chaque année moi
halloween c'est ça je suis refait je
vous dis tout de suite
tu pars avec la Fiat et tu reviens
l'année prochaine
[Applaudissements]
merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo
joyeux Halloween
à la maison
[Applaudissements]
la dernière incroyable les photos elle
sort d'où c'est photos de nous c'est pas
une photo que j'ai sur Instagram